[موسيقى]
السلام عليكم اهلا بكم في حصاه الليله
معكم محمد كريشان وفي الحصاد ننقل لكم
الاجواء في مدن وعواصم شهدت احداث المهمه
البدايه من رام الله بالضفه الغربيه
المحتله ويوم جديد من التصعيد مستوطن
اسرائيلي يقتل فلسطينيا قرب قلقيليه
اقتحامات مستمره ومواجهات في بلده علين
غربا رام الله
والى العاصمه الفرنسيه باريس التي شهدت
اليوم قمه بين ماكرون وسوناك لتجديد
الشراكه الفرنسيه البريطانيه اعلن في
خدامها ابرام اتفاق جديد بين لندن وباريس
للحد من موجات طالبيه اللجوء
واخيرا الى تبليسي عاصمه جورجيا التي شهدت
حشودا اليوم امام البرلمان للاحتفال بسحب
مشروع قانون مثير للجدل حول تصنيف
المنظمات غير الحكوميه عملاء اجانب
وفي مواضيع الحصاد هذه الليله
في بيان من بيجين ايران والسعوديه تعلنان
استئناف العلاقات الرياض تقول ان الاتفاق
يعكس رؤيتها بتفضيل الحوار وطهران تتحدث
عن مواصله العمل نحو مزيد من الخطوات
الاقلبيه
تصف الاتفاق بانه نصر للسلام البيت الابيض
يقول انه ليس واضحا ما اذا كان الاتفاق
سيؤثر على اتفاقيات دراهم
مع استمرار الاتهامات الغربيه لايران بدعم
روسيا بالمسيرات تقارير امريكيه تتحدث عن
تسليم موسكو لطهران انظمه عسكريه بينها
جافل كانت استولت عليها في اوكرانيا وتشير
الى تصاعد محتمل في التعاون العسكري بين
روسيا وايران
وحديث عن ابرام صفقه لشراء طائرات سوقي 35
بين روسيا وايران
فاجنر تعزز مواقعها في شرقي بخموت وتتحدث
عن هجوم مضاد محتمل من الجانب الاوكراني
والقوات الاوكرانيه تقول انها تواصل
الدفاع عن مواقعها
وفي ارتدادات الحرب واشنطن تتهم موسكو
بزعزعه استقرار مولدوفا وتنصيب حكومه
صديقه لروسيا
يوم جديد من التصعيد الاسرائيلي في الضفه
الغربيه
قوات الاحتلال تقتل فتى فلسطينيا في
قلقيليه مستوطن يقتل فلسطينيا بزعم
محاولته تنفيذ عمليه طعن وتحركات امريكيه
اوروبيه لخفض التوتر
في لقاءنا اليومي قبل الحصاد على منصاتنا
الرقميه ناقشنا معكم ما اعلنته وكاله
الانباء السعوديه من ان الرياض وطهران
اتفقتا على استئناف العلاقات الدبلوماسيه
واعاده فتح السفارتين والممثليات
الدبلوماسيه في غضون شهرين الوكاله ذكرت
ان التوصل الى هذا الاتفاق جاء عقب
مباحثات جرت في الصين مع الرئيس الصيني
ارائكم بشان هذا الموضوع كنا قد طرحنا
عليكم السؤال التالي الذي يقول ملا
انعكاسات المحتمله لاستئناف العلاقات بين
السعوديه وايران النتائج جاءت على النحو
التالي اثنان وخمسون بالمئه قالوا ان
الاستئناف العلاقات بين البلدين انعكاسات
اقليميه بينما صوت 15% لصالح وجود
انعكاسات اقتصاديه بالاساس فيما ذهب ثلاثه
33% مرشحين ان تكون هناك انعكاسات امنيه
وراء استئناف العلاقات بين الرياض وطهران
هذا السؤال سيبقى كالعاده مطروحا على
منصاتنا الرقميه ويمكنكم دخول صفحه
التصويت عبر مسح رمز كيو ار الظاهر حاليا
على الشاشه
لقائنا على المنصات الرقميه يتجدد يوميا
ونتطرق خلاله لقضايا مستجده ومتفاعله
عربيا ودوليا
وتتابعون في الحصاد ايضا
[موسيقى]
في سبقه تاريخيه رئيس الصيني
يفوز بولايه ثالثه بعد تصويت مجلس نواب
الشعب له بالاجماع
[موسيقى]
وكاله الانباء السعوديه ان الرياض وطهران
اتفقتا على استئناف العلاقات الدبلوماسيه
واعاده فتح السفارتين والممثليات
الدبلوماسيه في غضون شهرين الوكاله ذكرت
كذلك ان التوصل الى هذا الاتفاق جاء عقب
مباحثات جرت في الصين مع الرئيس الصيني
واضافه الوكاله ان المباحثات جاءت رغبه من
طهران والرياض في حل الخلافات بالحوار
والدبلوماسيه ونقلت عن بيانا سعودي صينيا
ايراني ان وزيري خارجيه البلدين سيجتمعان
لترتيب تبادل السفراء ومناقشه سبل تعزيز
العلاقات واشارت وكاله علماء السعوديه الى
ان الرياض وطهران اتفقت على تفعيل اتفاقيه
التعاون الامني بينهما كما اتفقتا على
احترام سياده الدول وعدم التدخل في شؤونها
الداخليه وقال مستشار الامن الوطني
السعودي يساعد بن محمد العباد ان الترحيب
بمبادره الصين ياتي انطلاقا من نهج التمسك
بمبا دئ حسن الجوار وتعزيز الامن
وزير الخارجيه السعوديه الامير فيصل بن
فرحان قال ان استئناف العلاقات
الدبلوماسيه بين بلادي وايران ياتي
انطلاقا من رؤيه المملكه القائمه على
تفضيل الحلول السياسيه والحوار واضاف
الوزير السعوديه في تغريده ان دول المنطقه
يجمعها مصير واحد وقواسم مشتركه تجعل من
الضروره ان تتشارك سويا لبناء نموذج
للازدهار والاستقرار حسب تعبيره
اما نظيره الايراني حسين امير عبد الهيان
فقال ان سياسه حسن الجوار التي تنتهجها
حكومه ابراهيم رئيسي تسير في الاتجاه
الصحيح
امينو مجلس الامن القوميه الايرانيه علي
شمخاني الذي كان مشاركا على راس الوفد
الايراني في بجين قال ان طهران اتفقت مع
الرياض على فتح صفحه جديده بناء على مصالح
البلدين والامن الاقليمي واضاف ان طهران
تامل ان يخلق ان يخلق هذا الاتفاق توازنا
في سلوك القوى الاجنبيه بالمنطقه حسب
تعبيره
نحن هنا منذ سته ايام في بيجين واجريت
مباحثات مع نظير السعودي توجت باتفاق
تطبيع العلاقات اتفقنا مع السعوديه على
فتح صفحه جديده مبنيه على مصالح البلدين
والامن الاقليمي وعلى تعزيز الاستقرار
بدلا من تفاقم التوتر ونامل ان يسهم في
احلال الامن والتنميه بالمنطقه وخلق توازن
في سلوك القوه الاجنبيه وابعادها عن منطقه
التي دخلتها دون اذن نتطلع الى ان يسهم
ذلك في ترسيخ علاقاتنا ليس مع السعوديه
فحسب بل مع دول المنطقه والعالم الاسلامي
العدو لا سيما الكيان الصهيوني يشعر
بالاحباط والياس من هذا الاتفاق
وفي اول رد فعل رسميا اسرائيليه على
استئناف العلاقات السعوديه الايرانيه
اعتبر مسؤول اسرائيلي في احاطه رسميه ان
هذا الاتفاق بين الطرفين سيؤثر على
امكانيه تطبيع العلاقات بين الرياض وتل
ابيب لكن المسؤول الاسرائيلي اضاف ان قوه
الغرب في موقفه من ايران
ستقلل من اهميه تطبيق العلاقات بين الرياض
وطهران حسب تعبيره
هذا وقد مرت العلاقه بين طهران والرياض
بمحطات تحسن وتوتر خلال العقود الماضيه في
التقرير التالي نتعرف على ابرز هذه
المحطات
تاثرت العلاقه بين السعوديه وايران بكثير
من التوتر المؤدي الى القطيعه والمصالحه
المؤديه الى الاتفاق عام واحد بعد وصول
الثوره الاسلاميه الى الحكم في طهران عام
79 توترت العلاقه بسبب الحرب العراقيه
الايرانيه اتهمت ايران السعوديه بدعم صدام
حسين في الحرب لكن العلاقه لم تصل حد
القطيعه طيله سنوات الحرب الثمانيه انتهت
الحرب بقطيعه ايرانيه سعوديه عام 88 تسعه
اعوام من القطيعه انتهت بوصول محمد خاتمي
الى سده الحكم في طهران عماني فقط بعد ذلك
زار خاتم السعوديه عادت العلاقات عام 99
بعد عامين في 2021 تحسنت العلاقات
الثنائيه حتى توقيع اتفاق امني بين
الطرفين الهدف مكافحه الارهاب وتهريب
المخدرات
ملفات اقليميه رسمت خطوط التوتر من جديد
من العراق وسوريا الى اليمن ولبنان بعد 15
سنه تعرضت السفاره السعوديه في طهران
للهجوم فقررت الرياض قطع العلاقات
الدبلوماسيه سنوات شد وجذب في العلاقه بين
الطرفين بدات بالهدوء مع تحركات الوساطات
الاخيره نجح العراق وعمان في عقد اجتماعات
مشتركه لمسؤولين الايرانيين والسعوديين
خلال العامين الماضيين توجت هذه اللقاءات
بتوقيع اتفاق عوده العلاقات في بيجين التي
استضافت مباحثات حاسمه نجحت بعد سبع سنوات
من القطيعه في العاشر من مارس عام 2023
نظامه الان من طهران الدكتور محمد حسين
هاشمي الدبلوماسيه الايرانيه السابق ومن
الرياض الدكتور سالم اليامي المستشار
السابق في وزاره الخارجيه السعوديه اهلا
بضيفينا نبدا من الرياض والدكتور اليامي
الان بعد هذا الترحيب بالاتفاق ماذا ننتظر
بسم الله الرحمن الرحيم احييك استاذ محمد
احيي السيدات والساده المشاهدين واشكركم
لكريم الاستضافه يعني العلاقات السعوديه
الايرانيه اليوم وفي هذا التاريخ تمر يعني
نقطه مفصليه هذه النقطه هي عوده العلاقات
واعلان الاطراف بقناعاتهم الذاتيه وانا
اعتقد ان ما يمكن الحديث عنه اليوم في هذه
النقطه او التصورات العامه لما حدث اليوم
لهذا الاعلان هو نجاح الجانب الصيني في
يعني اقناع الجانب السعودي او تقليل
المخاوف التي ربما كانت الى الجانب
السعودي الشيء الثاني هو دفع الجانب
الايراني ليكون اكثر مرونه لان جانب
الايراني كان لديه بعض المسارات ربما
المتعلقه بالرؤيه السياسيه الايرانيه في
المنطقه ورؤيه هذه المملكه كقوه اقليميه
تستطيع ان اقوله كخلاصه او كعنوان عريض ان
العلاقات اليوم هي
تصحح هناك تصحيح للعلاقات السعوديه
الايرانيه ربما يدخل العلاقه بين الجانبين
والمنطقه في حاله يعني تقليل للضغط او
تقليل للاحتقان السياسي والامني والعسكري
في المنطقه
كثيرا نظرت دول المنطقه الدكتور محمد حسين
هاشمي ما نظرت دول المنطقه الى ايران
بالكثير من الريبه بعد هذا الاتفاق هل
تعتقد بان الثقه ستحل محل هذه الربا
بسم الله الرحمن الرحيم تحيه لك
ولضيف الكريم وللمستمعين والمشاهدين
بسم الله الرحمن الرحيم اللي الواقع ان
الاتفاق الذي حصل هذا الاسبوع او خلال هذا
الاسبوع والذي اعلن عنه قبل ساعات
جاء في الواقع على خلفيه لقاءات سابقه في
بغداد وعمان
وكان من المفروض ان يكون هناك تواصل
دبلوماسي قبل ان يحصل هذا اللقاء في بجين
هذا الاسبوع ولكن بمبادره من الرئيس
الصيني ومن القياده السعوديه والقياده
الايرانيه حصل هذا الاتفاق الذي في الواقع
حصل بكل شفافيه ووضوح ووضع النقاط على
الحروف كما يقال اذا هناك خطوه قبل ان
تسبقها يسبقها لقاء دبلوماسي
اللقاء كان مهم جدا للغايه
وكان صريحا وشفافا وطرحت الكثير من
المسائل على طاوله الحوار قبل كل شيء
العلاقات الثنائيه بين المملكه العربيه
السعوديه وايران التي شابهها كما اشار
ضيفكم الكريم وكما اشرت حضرتك شابه الكثير
خلال السنوات الماضيه ولكن اتفاق اليوم
وضع حده لقطيعه طالت العلاقات لمده سبع
سنوات عجاف بين البلدين اليوم البلدين
وصلوا الى قناعه ان هذه ان هذه القطيعه
وان هذا هذه المواجهه والتقابل
ليس بمصلحتهما ليس بمصلحه البلدين بل
بمصلحه عدو العدو الاول لهذه الدولتين وهو
وهي دوله اسرائيل
وهذا التقابل وهذا الصراع ايضا يكلف
الجانبين الكثير اذا هناك قناعه راسخه
الان لبدء حوار ولبدا صفحه جديده من
العلاقات ستكون لصالح البلدين في الدرجه
الاولى ولصالح بلدان المنطقه في المرحله
الثانيه وتحديدا فيما يتعلق بدول المنطقه
الدكتور سالم اليافي الكل يقول بان هذا
الاتفاق سيساهم في تخفيض التوتر في
المنطقه لو نفصل اكثر ماذا نتوقع
يعني تعرف استاذ محمد اول شيء انا اليامي
وليس اليافيه بس لتصحيح هذا
حقك علي تفضل لا لا ولا يهمك يا سيدي
الجزئيه الاخرى الجزئيه الاخرى اخي الكريم
وهي في صلب السؤال هو الجسد السياسي
العربي في العقدين الاخيرين مره بمجموعه
من التحديات ومجموعه من التغيرات هذه
التحديات وهذه التغيرات كان
للسياسات الايرانيه كثير من الادوار التي
اضافت ابعادا سلبيه لهذه العلاقات واذا
اردت تفصيلا اكثر انا اقول لك انظر الى
الخارطه العربيه ابتداء من العراق ووضعها
السياسي والوضع المهزوز للسلطه الرسميه
وبروز ما يسمى بالميليشيات وثم انتقل الى
سوريا وتعرف الدوره الايراني السلبي الذي
يعني اثر على السياسه السوريه وربما عزلها
عن محيطها
العربي ويعني هذه العزلات تزيد يوما عن
يوم انظر الى المشاكل السياسيه
والاقتصاديه والمجتمعيه في لبنان ايضا
هناك يدايرانيه وهناك دورا ايراني لا يمكن
اخفاءه انظر ايضا الى التوتر في جنوب شبه
الجزيره العربيه في اليمن حيث هناك فاعلون
ما دون الدوله ويعني تنظيمات خارجه على
القانون ومختطفه للسلطه تدعم ودعمت
ايرانيا وهذا لا يمكن انكاره اذا انا اجيب
على سؤالك بهذه الصوره العامه انا اعتقد
ايران لم تقم بريئه وليست بريئه وكان لها
يد في خلق هذا الجسد السياسي المنهك
والمتعب وربما غير المتوازن اليوم نتمنى
في الحقيقه ان يعني تتخلى ايران عن تلك
الادوار السلبيه وان تتحلى بصفات الدوله
لا صفات الثوره بصفات الدوله التي تحترم
حقوق الجوار وتح التعاون الاقليمي وتحترم
ايضا يعني الايرادات العربيه وتقلل قدر
الامكان وربما بشكل يكون قطعيا التدخل في
الشؤون العربيه هذه في تقديره هي المسارات
التي يعني يؤمل منها ان تنتج ربما كاحد
اشكال هذا الاتفاق وانا اعتقد ان هناك
اصرار سعودي على كثير من هذه النقاط
وطالما الدكتور محمد حسين الهاشمي الشرط
الى الصراحه والشفافيه في مجمل هذه
الملفات التي كان يتحدث عنها الدكتور
اليامي ما الذي يمكن ان يتحسن عمليا
الواقع ان هذا القلق او ان هذه النظره
السلبيه الى الى الى ايران والى ما قامت
به ايران هذا متبادل يعني هناك نظره سلبيه
وهناك قلق امني ايضا لدى ايران ولد الدوله
الايرانيه والمجتمع الايراني اتجاه الدوري
السعودي في المنطقه هذا هذا في الواقع
متبادل بين الطرفين ليس هذا من الجانب
السعودي فقط ايضا نحن ننظر بغيبه الى
الكثير مما حصل خلال الفتره المنصرمه الان
نريد ان نفتح صفحه جديده ولكن في الواقع
هناك جروح أقد تكون بعضها عميقه بعضها
عميقه كاليمن مثلا لان هناك احتلال في
اليمن من قبل المملكه العربيه السعوديه
وهناك تدخل في الشان اللبناني وهناك تدخل
في الشان السوري وكل ما اشار له الضيف
الكريم هناك في المقابل قلق ايراني عميق
من الدور السعودي في المنطقه وفي الكثير
من الدول التي اليها الاستاذ نحن الان
مصممون
والاتفاق الواقع يشير الى ان هناك قناعه
راسخه لدى الطرفين ان يطون صفحه الماضي
ويبداون صفحه جديده من التعاون والتالف
وهذا سيكون في مصلحه البلدين ومصلحه دول
المنطقه وسيعود بالامن والسلم لكافه الدول
لان هناك ملفات مهمه طرحت
على الطاوله من قبل من قبل الطرفين وبحثت
وهناك امل كبير نصل الى نتائج طيبه تعود
تعود بالصلاح بكافه الدول المنطقه
وللبلدين خاصه شكرا لك دكتور محمد حسين
هاشمي من طهران شكرا لك دكتور سالم اليامي
من الرياض
هذا وقد وصف وزير الخارجيه الصيني
استئناف العلاقات الدبلوماسيه بين الرياض
وطهران وصفه بانه نصر للحوار والسلام
ان بلاده ادت واجبها بكل امانه باعتبارها
وسيطا موثوقا به والدوله المضيفه
للمحادثات السعوديه الايرانيه واضاف انما
تخللت به محادثات بجين يزف انباء طيبه
عظيمه في وقت يشهد فيه العالم كثيرا من
الاضطرابات على حد قولهم
وفي ردود الفعل قال منسق للاتصالات
الاستراتيجيه في البيت الابيض جونغكوربي
ان السعوديين ابلغوا واشنطن باتصالاتهم مع
الايرانيين لكن لم يكن للولايات المتحده
دور في الاتفاقيه واكد كربي ان ما يهم
واشنطن وانهاء الحرب في اليمن ووقف
الهجمات على السعوديه مشددا على ان
الولايات المتحده سترى ما اذا كانت ايران
ستفي بالتزاماتها بعد ابرامها هذه
الاتفاقيه مع السعوديه مضيفا انه ليس
واضحا بعد ما اذا كانت الاتفاقيه السعوديه
مع ايران ستؤثر على اتفاقيات ابراهام
ينضم الينا الان من بيجين فيكتور جو نائب
رئيس مركز الصين والعولمه ومن واشنطن
السفير بجيكراولي المتحدث السابق باسم
الخارجيه الامريكيه والذي نبدا به لنساله
لماذا بدت واشنطن حذره نوعا ما في الحكم
على هذه الاتفاقيه السعوديه الايرانيه
انا اعتقد ان من المهم جدا ان هذين
الغريمين قد عاد وسنف العلاقات
الدبلوماسيه هم بلدان مهمان في الشرق
الاوسط وهم يواجهون توترا كبيرا في
العلاقه بينها وبالتالي من المهم جدا
لهذين البلدين ان يعودا الى التحدث سويه
لكن كما قلنا راينا هنالك استئناف
للعلاقات بين الولايات المتحده مع روسيا
مثلا لكن العلاقات سيئه الان وكان هنالك
علاقات دبلوماسيه مع الصين والولايات
المتحده ايضا لكنها تشهد صعوبات الان ايضا
بالتالي نعم هذه خطوه مهمه للبلدين الصين
تستحق الاشاده بدورها بهذه المبادره لكن
علينا ان ننتظر ونرى اذا ما كانت العلاقات
الدبلوماسيه باستطاعتها بمرور الوقت ان
تقلل التوتر وتستمر
بالبقاء بين الدولتين ولكن هل هل تبدو
واشنطن منزعجه بين قوسين من ان الصين هي
التي اخذت هذا المجد كوسيط وبان الصلح تم
مع ايران واعلاقه ايران بواشنطن ليست على
ما يرام
مره اخرى من علينا ان نشيد بدوري الصين هي
لديها علاقات مع ايران والمملكه العربيه
السعوديه ولعبت هذا الدور الفعال حقيقه ان
الولايات المتحده لا علاقات دبلوماسيه مع
ايران بالتالي هي لا تستطيع ان تقوم
بالدور
تجري الحديث الذي حصل في بيجي ما راينا
حصوله خلال السنتين الماضيتين حيث كان
هنالك محادثات فيينا من اجل احيائي
الاتفاق النووي الايراني رفضت ايران ان
تلتقي مباشره مع نظراء الايرانيه ان نتحدث
اليهم عبر الوسطاء بالتالي هذا الدور ليس
في الولايات المتحده لم تكن فيه
لتلعبه في المقابل هذا الدور لعبته الصين
السيد فيكتور جاو هل ارادت بجين ان تقول
بانها
لاعب اساسي وبامكانها ان تنجز
ما لم يستطع غيرها ان ينجزه ربما
بدايه اليوم هو يوم عظيم للدبلوماسيه ويوم
عظيم للسلام نحن نهنئ المملكه العربيه
السعوديه وايران اللي اظهارهم الحكمه
والرؤيه والشجاعه في تحقيق هذا التطبيق
واستئناف العلاقات بين البلدين كلا من
ايران والسعوديه هما بلدان مهماني جدا ليس
فقط في ذلك جزء من العالم لكن في العالم
باكملها وان يكون من يكونا قاده في
بالنسبه للمملكه العربيه السعوديه في
العالم الاسلامي السني وبالنسبه لايران في
العالم
الاسلامي الشيعي بالتالي الصين تتمتع
بعلاقات جيده مع السعوديه ولديها علاقات
جيده جدا ايضا مع ايران من الجانب الاخر
الصين دائما تعامل السعوديه والايران
كالدول والحلفاء متكافئين ونحن نحترم كلا
البلدين بالنسبه للصين لكي تلعب هذا الدور
المهم وتبدا الجهود المهمه وتلعب دور
الوسيط هو مصدر شرف وفرح للصين ونامل ان
السلام والتطبيع بين ايران والسعوديه لن
يكون
حدثا منفردا بل سيكون حدثا مستمرا ودعني
اقول لك ان السلام لا يتحقق بالسهوله
السلام بامر صعب للغايه وقد يتطلب وقتا
طويلا للسعوديه ولايران لكي يصل الى حل
لجميع الخلافات لكن الوصول الى هذه النقطه
هي خطوه مهمه في الاتجاه الصحيح واليوم
دعونا نحيي الايران والسعوديه اللي لهذا
الانجاز العظيم ودعونا نكون
متحلينا بالتفاؤل ونعمل نحو نحو الافضل
واعمل انه الدول الاخرى ستقوم بنفس الدور
الذي لعبته الصين هو ان تقف ثابته
الى جانب السلام وتدعم السلام والتعاون
والشراكه
هو تحاول ان تتفادى
زياده التوتر في ذلك الجزء من العالم وفي
انحاء العالم باكمله هذه الاتفاقيه سيد
كراولي او هذه هذا الاتفاق بين طهران
والرياض طبخ على مدى الاشهر الماضيه وعلى
الاقل خمس جولات في بغداد ولكن في النهايه
التتويج كان صينيا هل تعتقد بان ايران
اعطت هذه الورقه الى الى الصين بشكل مقصود
يصعب علي الجزم ايران قد طورت علاقات
استراتيجيه مع الصين وهي ايضا قامت بتطوير
علاقه استراتيجيه مع روسيا وليس هنالك اي
شيء من وجهه نظر ايران هي تحاول ان تستخدم
هذه العلاقات من اجل ان يكون لها نفوذ
وتضغط على الولايات المتحده لكن كقاعده
عامه الدول تعمل لخدمه مصالحها الخاصه
بالتالي من مصلحه ايران ان تتمتع بعلاقات
مع السعوديه ومن مصلحه المملكه العربيه
السعوديه ان تتمتع بعلاقه جيده مع ايران
وان تحاول ان تقلل من التوتر بالتالي على
ذلك المستوى الامر لا يتعلق بالولايات
المتحده على الرغم انه ليس لدي اي شك من
ان طهران استمتعت بهذه
المبادره والتي لم تكن الولايات المتحده
جزءا منها شكرا جزيلا لك يا سفير
واشنطن وفيكتور جاو من بيجين
[موسيقى]
نقلت شبكه انا الامريكيه عن من سمتها
مصادر مطلعه ان روسيا ارسلت لايران اسلحه
ومعدات امريكيه وغربيه استولت عليها في
اوكرانيا منها انظمه جابلن وستنجر ونقلت
الوكاله تسنيم من جهتها عن ممثل ايران لدى
الامم المتحده ان طهران ابرمت اتفاقيه مع
روسيا لتزويدها بطائرات خمسه وثلاثين
امريكيه وغربيه استولت عليها في اوكرانيا
منها انظمه
هذا ما نقلته محطه سي ان ان عمن سمتها
مصادر مطلعه وستنجر هو من احدث الصواريخ
الامريكيه الصنع المضاده للطائرات
والمروحيات والمسيرات يحقق ستينجر نظام
دفاع جوي في الجبهات الاماميه ويستخدم في
دعم المراحل الاولى من عمليات القوات
المحموله جوا اما تشافلان فهي صواريخ
مضاده للدروع تعتمد في مسيرها بعد الاطلاق
مسيره الرمح اي تطير بعد اطلاقها الى
الاعلى ثم تسقط عموديا على الهدف وهو ما
قد يعزز من قدره القتال الميدانيه
ومن ثم فان حصول ايران على نماذج من
الصاروخين قد يصب في خانه تعزيز دفاعاتها
الجويه والميدانيه بحسب صحيفه نيويورك
تايمز التي كشفت ايضا عن معلومات مفادها
ان طهران تستعد لتسلم مقاتلات السخوي خمسه
لتعلن طهران اتمام الصفقه بحسب وكاله
تسنيم بالتوازي مع ذلك سربت صحيفه نيويورك
تايمز ما قالت انها صور اقمار صناعيه تظهر
قاعده عسكريه جويه ايرانيه وما يمكن ان
تكون طائره سخوي لكن لماذا يخشى الغرب
وقوع اسلحه امريكيه بيد ايران الجواب يكمن
في توسع التعاون العسكري الروسي الايراني
تحالف يقول عنه مدير وكاله المخابرات
المركزيه الامريكيه ويليامبرز انه يتحرك
بسرعه كبيره في اتجاه خطير للغايه في
الوقت الحالي
تحرك قد يتضمن تبادلا في مجال التصنيع
العسكري بين طهران وموسكو والهندسه
العكسيه اي اعاده انتاج اسلحه غربيه في
مصانع عسكريه محليه
فصحيفه تتحدث عن مضاعفه ايران الدعم
العسكريه لروسيا في سلسله من الصفقات
الجديده التي يمكن ان تعزز من ترسانتها من
الاسلحه وتعتبر مسيرات شاهد من ابرز
الاسلحه التي يتهم الغرب طهران بارسالها
الى موسكو بينما توفر هذه الصفقات لطهران
شرايين دفاعيه جديده وفقا للصحيفه وقد
تكون من بينها انظمه اس 3400
[موسيقى]
وينضم الينا هنا في الاستوديو الدكتور عبد
الله الشاذجي استاذ العلوم السياسيه في
جماعه الكويت ومعنا من واشنطن الدكتور
خليل العناني استاذ العلوم السياسيه
والعلاقات الدوليه اهلا بهما اهلا وسهلا
بك دكتور
رغم ان الموضوع يبدو عسكريا بحثا ولكن هل
يمكن ان نقدم له قراءه سياسيه هذا الموضوع
التعاون
المجال التقني والسلاح بين روسيا وايران
طبعا دولتين معزومتين دولتين عندهم مشكله
مع الغرب دولتين ينظر اليهم بانه يساعدان
بعضهم البعض ايران عندها مشكله كبيره تريد
ان ترفع العقوبات تريد ان تعود الى
الاتفاق النووي ولكن في نفس الوقت تصعد
بشكل كبير تدعم كما يتهم الامريكان
والنيتو انها تدعم قتل الاوكرانيين في
اوكرانيا على يد الجيش الروسي بتزويد طبعا
المسيرات الشاهد 136 الانتحاريه التي تقتل
المدنيين وتستهدف البنى التحتيه وخاصه
محطات توليد الكهرباء ونرى امس يعني حتى
امس استخدم بوتين في منطقه مسيرات ايرانيه
شاهد لضرب الاهداف المدنيه وكذلك الاهداف
البنى التحتيه فهذا يجعل ايران يعني دوله
لا يمكن حتى الاتفاق النووي ان يتم التوصل
اليه ثم ياتي ويصعد الادميرال البحري انه
يريد ان يرسل بارجه وحيده ايرانيه الى
اعالي البحار والمحيطات ويصعب بهذه
الطريقه فلهذا السبب يعني يساعدان بعضهم
البعض وايران ثلاث مرات امتنعت عن التصويت
لادانه
حرب روسيا على اوكرانيا ولكن في نفس الوقت
ليس تحالف استراتيجي
تحالف استراتيجي كيف تسمح روسيا لاسرائيل
بان تقصف بشكل متكرر ويمكن مرتين او ثلاث
مرات في الشهر حليفها
السوري وايران وميليشياته وحرسها الثوري
خاصه في الشمال باغلاق الرادارات روسيا
لعدم استهداف الطائرات الاسرائيليه فهذا
ليس تحالف استراتيجي بل تحالف وقتي لفائده
الطرفين اذا ما تاكد ما قالته سينان
الدكتور خليل العناني هل هذا مقلق بشكل
جدي لواشنطن
الى حد بعيد طبعا استاذ محمد اولا مساء
الخير لحضرتك والدكتور عبد الله المشاهدين
مساء الخير طبعا مغلق عده اسباب الاول
يتعلق انه نتكلم على
فك العزله بشكل اخر عن روسيا التي تم
فرضها على الاقل عامل ماضي خاصه بما يتعلق
باسلحه مهمه جدا وهي اسلحه
دكتور عبد الله استهدف بها التحتيه
الاوكرانيه واعطت روسيا نفس جديد في الحرب
على مدار الشغل الماضيه الامر الثاني
متعلق في خطوره امكانيه اعاده تدوير هذه
الاسلحه التي تم يعني ارسالها بشكل اخر
لايران سواء انظمه
او استجنر المضاده للطائرات عدد مصنعها
بشكل يناسب
الساحه المعركه في اوكرانيا هذا بيعني
اولا امكانيه
الحرب بين الروس والاويران اعتمد روسيا
الامر الثاني مخاوف امريكيه من اعاده
التوازن الاستراتيجي في المنطقه من خلال
اولا اعطاء ايران منظمات دفاعيه وصاروخيه
هي في حاجه اليها بشكل كبير الامر الثاني
احتماله
انظمه جافل في ايدي حلفاء يرى سواء كان
حزب الله في لبنان سواء كان الفلسطينيه
سواء كان الحوثيين يعمل
استراتيجي في المعركه
امريكيه حقيقيه هذا الموضوع ليس الامر
اليوم او
الامساحات على مدار اخر تم تسع شهور هناك
تزايد في المخاوف الامريكيه من وقود شراكه
استراتيجيه عسكريه بين رغبه
الدكتور عنان استعمل كلمه استراتيجيه انت
لا تراها كذلك كتعاون عسكري تحالف
استراتيجي يعني بتحالف مصلحي ووقتي وظرفي
لان التحالف الاستراتيجي يعني اعمق
التحالف استراتيجي يعني طبعا يعني روسيا
تريد ان تستغل لايران من اجل ان تعزز او
لان المصانعها غير كافيه لاعاده انتاج
الاسلحه التي قاعد تخسرها بشكل كبير في
عامها الثاني في اوكرانيا ولكن انا اللي
يقلقنا في دول الخليج هو بالفعل تزويد
روسيا لايران
بمقاتلات سخوي 35 ايران طبعا معروف انها
عندها اسطول طيران عربي متراحل جدا وقديم
من ايام الشاه ومعظم ثلثه واكثر غير صالح
للاستخدام فتعزيز هذه المنظومه 35 مع انها
اقل قدره في المناوره وفي القتال من افسد
والمقاتلات الامريكيه لنملك في دول وقف 18
في الكويت والامارات وقطر ولكن مع ذلك
ستخل بميزان القوى نحن اسلحتنا كلها
تقريبا دفاعيه وليست هجوميه معترضه
وهجوميه وتخل بميزان القوه وهذه كانت
مخصصه لمصر اصلا ب 2019 شهرتها مصر ولكن
بسبب الضغط الامريكي الان تم تجميد الصفقه
ولكن بوتين قاعد يلعب لعبه خطيره بتسليح
وتزويد ايران والتعامل معها بالسخوي
وتعامل معها بالدرونز الانتحاريه ليخل
بموازين القوى وهي رساله لامريكا ان
استطيع انا ان ازعزع الامن في الخليج
بقدر ان يهدد حتى مصالح امريكا ومثل ما
ذكر صديقي الدكتور العناني انها تزويد
ايضا تعمد بوتين تزويد هذا الصاروخ
الستنجر الذي يسقط الطائرات
والمجاهدين الافغان والعرب استخدموه
بكثافه في حرب افغان لما احتلت الاتحاد
السوفيتي تحت الافغانستان تسعه وثمانين
وكان احد اسباب هزيمه السوفييت في
افغانستان وكذلك جوفلند صاروخ جدا متطور
ضد الدبابات وضد المدرعات الروسيه هذا اذا
اعطي لايران يصير عندها قدره ان تفكك هذه
الاليه تفهم منظومتها وتتعامل مع
الامريكان ندا في اكثر من موقع والخطوره
ان تسرب هذه الاسلحه لحلفاء ايران
ووكلائها في المنطقه مما يزيد من حده
التصعيد والتوتر بدلا ما يخفضها حسب الان
الاتفاق مع السعوديه ومع ومع ايران عبر
وساطه صينيه لتدخل لاول مره في مناطق نفوذ
امريكا بشكل غير مسبوق ولكن هذا الاتفاق
الذي اعلن في الصين دكتور خليل العناني
وفي الاجواء التي كان يتحدث عنها الان
الدكتور عبد الله الشاجي الا يمكن ان يجعل
ط هران
تتريث نوعا ما في ان تستفيد من كل هذه
النقاط العسكريه في ارباك المنطقه هي
ستحتفظ بها كنقات قوه ولكن لن تستعملها
الى حد بعيد
حاول تستغل كل الاوراق المتاحه امامها من
اجل فعظيم بكاسها من اجل الضغط على
الامريكي قد يكون احد
بسيطه للحصول على جلب والحصول على متعلق
بالضغط على كلمه
اتفقنا على مدار الاسابيع الماضيه هناك
كان لهجه جديده امريكيه وايرانيه تتعلق
باحتمال استئناف المفاوضات فقر النووي قد
ياتي اتفاق اليوم ما بين السعوديه وايران
من اجل ان يهدي الاوضاع في المنطقه
العربيه اعطاء مساحه دبلوماسيه اعطاء
مساحه للحوار بين الطرفين السعودي
وبالتالي اعاده خلق الاوراق كل الاحوال
ايران تستفيد من كل الفرص المتاحه لديها
تحاول ان تغازل الغرب من خلال التعاون
الروسي الايراني انا اعتقد ان التعاون
الروسي الايراني هو اقل من تحالف واكبر من
التعاون انا سميته شراكه استراتيجيه على
الاقل مؤقتا لكن الناس استريحيه بمعنى
انها تمثل تحولا في موازين القوى سواء
فيما يتعلق بالحرب الداخليه في اوكرانيا
او فيما يتعلق بمنطقه العربيه
ايران كما قلت بانظمه الصاروخ الدفاعيه
ببطاقه وبالتالي يعتبر تحول بشكل اخر في
الامكانيات العسكريه في المنطقه العسكريه
ايران تتعامل بشكل تاكي جدا هي لا تستعجل
في يعني
الروسيه قد تستخدم غدا الورق الصينيه
وهكذا فيما مغادره امريكا من اجل دفع
باتجاه اتفاق النووي الايراني في المستقبل
القريب اذا امكن الفصل ذلك شكله اخر
لديك اضافه سريعه جدا يعني طبعا في تقارير
استخباراتيه امريكيه اعلنت في بعض المراكز
الدراسات تقول بان هناك مطالب او او
لقاءات مع بين دول خليجيه او مع روسيا مع
بوتين شخصيا وكذلك اسرائيل
لتاخير هذه الصفقه او الغاءها او اذا لا
يمكن الغاء
التي ستمنع اسرائيل من توجيه ضربات عسكريه
للبرنامج النووي الايراني او منشات
النوويه وهذا طبعا دليل على ان هناك
بالفعل
مسافه جيده بين دول الخليج وبين روسيا
مؤخرا قبل ايام زار وزير الخارجيه السعودي
روسيا ولهذا السبب هناك تقارب وهناك تفاهم
ولكن من يملك اوراق القوه هي روسيا وليس
ايران شكرا لك دكتور عبد الله الشايجي على
حضورك معنا شكرا لك دكتور خليل العناني من
واشنطن
ومباشره بعد ان نتابع التطورات الميدانيه
في اوكرانيا نعود لتسطيط المزيد من الضوء
على خبر ارسال روسيا لايران اسلحه ومعدات
امريكيه وغربيه استولت عليها في اوكرانيا
ونسال ضيف المتابعه عن الاهميه العسكريه
لحصول طهران على هذه الاسلحه
[موسيقى]
في تطوراته حرب روسيا على اوكرانيا اعلنت
ميليشيا فاجن الروسيه تعزيز مواقعها في
المناطق الشرقيه بمدينه باكموت متوقعه شن
القوات الاوكرانيه هجوما مضادا من جانبه
قال المتحدث باسم القوات الاوكرانيه في
الشرق ان القوات الروسيه تواصل محاوله شن
هجمات باتجاه وسط وفي البلدات المحيطه بها
مشيرا الى ان التصدي لعشرات الهجمات خلال
اقل من اربع وعشرين ساعه
على الجهه الاخرى للحدود ما بين اوكرانيا
ومولدوفا نقطه احتكاك اخرى بين روسيا
والغرب منطقه ترانس نسترع المواليه لروسيا
مسرح بتبادل اتهامات بين موسكو
لاستهداف مسؤولين محليين الكبار في
المقابل واشنطن تتهم موسكو بالسعي لاحداث
تمرد في مولدوفا وتتوعد بمزيد من العقوبات
في ركن من العالم لا تنقصه النزاعات وحروب
التصريحات اتهم رئيس منطقه ترانسنيستريا
الانفصاليه المواليه لروسيا اوكرانيا
بالوقوف وراء هجوم كان يستهدف مسؤولين
كبارا في المنطقه الاتهام جاء ساعات بعد
اعلان السلطات
الواقعه بين اوكرانيا ومولدوفا احباط هجوم
قالت ان الاجهزه الامنيه الاوكرانيه كانت
تعتزم فيه استهداف شخصيات بارزه في
المنطقه السلطات الاوكرانيه نددت بهذه
الاتهامات واعتبرتها استفزازا من تدبير
الكرملين في حين سبق لموسكو ان اعلنت
نهايه الشهر الماضي ان تحضر لمهاجمه
المنطقه غير المعترف باستقلالها دوليا
ويخشى ان يقدح هذا التوتر شراره حرب جديده
حيث طالما اعتقد الاوكرانيون ان روسيا
ستعمد لتفعيل جبهه ترانسنيستريا في اي
لحظه الشريط الرفيع الذي لا تتجاوز مساحته
4000 وخمسمائه كيلومتر مربع
لا تتجاوز نصف مليون نسمه سبقا اعلنت
استقلالها من جانب احادي سنه واحده بعد
انهيار الاتحاد السوفيتي وتحتفظ فيها
موسكو بكتابه لحفظ السلام كما تقول
وبكميات كبيره من الذخائر ويخشى
الاوكرانيون من فتح جبهه اخرى لمهاجمه
مدينه اوديسا التي تقع بالقرب منها تصمت
موسكو امام هذه التطورات لكن واشنطن تراقب
المشهد من بعيد حيث اتهم منسق الاتصالات
الاستراتيجيه في البيت الابيض جون كربي
روسيا بمحاوله خلق تمرد في مولدوفا
متواعدا الروس بمزيد من العقوبات ووعد
المولدوفا بتقديم مزيد من الدعم
اذا بالعوده
[موسيقى]
اذا بالعوده الى التقارير الامريكيه التي
تحدثت عن تسليم روسيا لايران منظومات
سلاحا ومعدات غربيه استولت عليها في
اوكرانيا نسال عن طبيعه تلك الاسلحه
والدواعي التي
تنقلها الى طهران اذا ما صحت نقلها من
طهران اذا صح ما تريده طبعا شبكه سي ان
الامريكيه في هذا الشعب وفقا للشبكه توجد
بين تلك المنظومات اسلحه محموله على الكتف
بما في ذلك منظومه صواريخ جافلين المضاده
للدبابات والصواريخ ستنجر المضاده
للطائرات وهي بعض من الاسلحه التي اجبرت
القوات الاوكرانيه على تركها في ساحات
المعارك لكن ماذا ستفعل ايران بتلك
الاسلحه تعتقد الولايات المتحده ان الجيش
الايراني سيحاول تفكيك منظومات السلاح
التي تسلمها من روسيا واجراء تحليل هندسي
عليها بهدف صناعه اسلحه مشابه مثل صاروخ
طوفان الذي يعتقد انه تم تصميمه بشكل عكسي
بناء على الصاروخ الامريكي بيجي امن 71
تاو لن يكون هذا التعديل الاول من نوعه
كما يبدو فمصادر
تشير الى ان طهران تقوم في الاساس بتعديل
الطائرات المسيره التي تقدمها لروسيا بحيث
يمكن للرؤوس الحربيه المتفجره ان تلحق
اضرارا قصوى باهداف البنيه التحتيه داخل
اوكرانيا وتعتقد موسكو بحسبك بحسب دائما
حسب شبكه
ايضا ان الاستمرار في تزويد طهران باسلحه
واشنطن وحلف الناتو التي تم الاستيلاء
عليها سيحفزها على مواصله دعمها للحرب
الروسيه في اوكرانيا اما في الجانب
الامريكي فيتعاظم القلق مما يعتقد انه سعي
ايراني لتعزيز الجيش بمساعده روسيه مقابل
اسلحه الى موسكو تستخدم في الحرب على
اوكرانيا تشتبه واشنطن بان طهران ارسلت
بالفعل الى موسكو مئات الطائرات المسيره
وكذلك ذخيره للمدفعيه والدبابات وفي
الرابعه والعشرين من فبراير شباط الماضي
قال البيت الابيض ان روسيا تدرس ارسال
طائرات مقاتله الى ايران في اطار تعاون
عسكري كما تعتقد الاداره الامريكيه ان
روسيا قد تنخرط في تعاون دفاعي غير مسبوق
مع ايران يشمل مجالات الصواريخ
والالكترونيات والدفاع الجوي
ينضموا الينا الان من عمان اللواء فايز
الدويري الخبير العسكري والاستراتيجي اهلا
وسهلا بك حضره اللواء
ما ابرز ما يلفت الانتباه في هذه الاخبار
انصحت طبعا من شبكه سي ان ان
يعني تقريبا الاستراتيجيه الرئيسيه في
الصناعات العسكريه الايرانيه هي تعتمد
الهندسه العسكريه
العكسيه
وبالتالي كافه الصواريخ دون استثناء وانت
ذكرت صاروخ طوفان صواريخ الباريسيه
وصواريخ ضد البحر
وصواريخ ضد الدرع وحتى دبابه كرار جميعها
اعتمدت مقاربه الهندسه العسكريه العكسيه
لان هذا هذا النوع مسموح به من قبل كثير
من الدول ولا يعتبر مخالف قانونيا الا من
قبل بعض الدول الاوروبيه وهذا يقدم الكثير
من اهمها يساعد على الابتكار يعني عفوا
على المقاطعه فقط حتى نفسر
سمعني بشكل جيد الصوت غير واضح الصوت غير
واضح خلينا نعيد السؤال
خلينا غير واضح لو سمحت تعيد السؤال نعيد
السؤال
الهندسه العكسيه لو لو تشرحها لنا اكثر
يبدو الهندسه العكسيه في الصوت الان صارت
مش مسموعه
اعيد السؤال
لو تركتها
اذا اذا سنعود
سنعود الى الهندسه العكسيه والى المساء
العسكريه بين روسيا
سنعود اليه سنعود اليك ننتقل الى الملف
الفلسطيني حيث يتواصل التصعيد الاسرائيلي
فقد اعلنت وزاره الصحه الفلسطينيه استشهد
فتى يبلغ من العمر 16 عاما برصاص الاحتلال
في قلقيليه وكان مستوطن اسرائيلي قد قتل
فلسطينيا قرب مدينه قلقيليه بذريعه
محاولته تنفيذ عمليه الطعن وافادت المصادر
ان المستوطن اطلق النار على الشاب
الفلسطيني بالقربي من مستوطنه معالي
شومرون زعما انه كان قادما الى مزرعته
حاملا سكاكين وموده ناسفه محليه السنه
وقد اقتحمت قوات الاحتلال الاسرائيليه
قريه سنيريا جنوب قلقيليه بالضفه الغربيه
وفتشت عددا من المنازل من بينها منزل بديع
الشيخ والد الشيخ عبد الكريم الشيخ الشهيد
عبد الكريم الشيخ في الاثناء اعتقلت قوات
الاحتلال الاسرائيلي فجر اليوم صلاح
الخواجه والد معتز الخواجه منفذي عمليه
اطلاق النار في شارع ديزنجوف في تل ابيب
كما اعتقلت احد اشقائه خلال اقتحامها بلده
نعلين غرب رام الله وقد دهمت قوات
الاحتلال منزل الخواجه وعاثت فيه خرابا
واجرت فيه مسحا هندسيا تمهيدا لهدمه
والتزامن ذلك مع مواجهات اندلعت بين عشرات
الفلسطينيين وقوات الاحتلال التي اطلقت
الرصاصه
وقنابل الغاز المسيل للدموع على المحتجين
في البلده ما اسفر عن جرح شابين فلسطينيين
واصابه العشرات اخرين بحالات اختناق
بالغاز
انا القياديه في جبهه الخلاصه الوطنيه في
تونس جوهر بن مبارك دخوله في اضراب عن
الطعام بسبب ما اعتبره تعمد اداره السجن
التنكيل به وتغيير مكان اقامته في ظروف
وصفها بالسيئه للغايه بتعليمات من سلطه
الانقلاب حسب ما جاء في منشور على صفحته
رسميه واعتبر المحامي هيئه الدفاع عنه
كريم المرزوقي ان دخول بعض الموقوفين في
اضراب عن الطعام هو نتيجه تراكميه لما
يحصل للمعتقلين منذ اسبوعين في السجن وقال
المرزوقي في منشورا على فيسبوك ان قرار
التنكيل بالمعتقلين قرار سياسي واضح بهدف
اذلالهم وكان النجم الناشط السياسي
والامين العام السابق لحزب التيار
الديمقراطي غازي الشواشي قد اكد في وقت
سابق دخول والده في اضراب عن الطعام رفضا
لسياسه التنكير به في السجن محمد الشواشي
في تدوينه عناصر امن السجن ومديره
وقاضي التحقيق ووزيره العدل والرئيس قيس
سعيد المسؤوليه عن صحه والدها
نعود مره اخرى الى اللواء فايز الدويري في
عمان لواء كنا نتحدث قبل انقطاع الصوت كنا
نتحدث عن اهميه ما ورد في
ذكرته ولكن توقفت عند اشارتك للهندسه
العكسيه لو تشرح لنا ما معنى الهندسه
العكسيه
[موسيقى]
البحث والتطوير تمكنك من اكتشاف نقاط
الضعف والاخطاء وتجاوزها في تصنيعك نعود
الى ايران تحديدا كافه الصواريخ
الباليستيه وصواريخ ضد الدرع وصواريخ ضد
القطع البحريه مطوره عنه اما صناعه صينيه
او صناعه روسيه او صناعه كوريه حتى دبابه
كرار هي صناعه عسكريه عكسيه عن دبابه تي 9
تي شكرا
وبالتالي اذا ما
هذه المعدات تحديدا في جمله واحده جافل
استنكر صواريخ ضد الدرع وصواريخ ضد الجو
ستكون تشكل قفز نوعيه شو تطور الصناعات
العسكريه الايرانيه شكرا لك لوفائز
الدويري من عمان
[موسيقى]
في خطوه غير مسبوقه فاز رئيس الصيني شي
جينج بفتره رئاسيه ثالثه وذلك خلال جلسه
لمجلس الشعب
[موسيقى]
بنسبه 100% من اصوات اعضاء مجلس النواب
الشعب فاز شيمبي بولايه ثالثه رئيسا للصين
فوز متوقع بعد التعديل الدستوري عام 2018
الذي الغى الشيى بموجبه محدوديه فتره
الرئاسه لولايتين فقط ما يفتح الباب امامه
لرئاسه مدى الحياه وخلال الادلاء بالقسم
اكد الشي على العمل لبناء دوله اشتراكيه
وديمقراطيه
اقسم ان اكون مخلصا لدستور جمهوريه الصين
الشعبيه
وان اعمل بجد لبناء دوله استراكيه حديثه
وديمقراطيه ومتحضره
جدد مجلس النواب الشعب ايضا ثقته في
الرئيس شي من خلال اعاده انتخابه على راس
اللجنه العسكريه المركزيه وهو ما يعادل
منصب القائد الاعلى للقوات المسلحه
الصينيه بعد عشر سنوات في السلطه يعزز
الرئيس الصيني شيبينغ مكانته بفتره رئاسيه
ثالثه قد تساهم في تعميق النفوذ الصيني
اقليميا وعالميا من خلال مبادرات طموحه
يعمل عليها شيك كمبادره الحزام والطريق
للاستثمار في الدول الاخرى مبادره ينظر
اليها الغرب على انها مستنقع من الديون
ستغرق فيه دول فقيره منها بلدان افريقيه
استثمارات صينيه بمليارات الدولارات في
البنيه التحتيه للدول الناميه تتهم بيجين
بانها تحاول الحصول من خلالها على موطئ
قدم لها في الموانئ الرئيسيه لهذه الدول
وتوسيع نفوذها الجيو السياسي بانشاء قواعد
عسكريه صينيه في كمبوديا وغيرها
في تعيين
سوداء خلال السنوات الخمس الماضيه احرزت
الصين انجازات سواء عالميا من خلال مبادره
الحزام والطريق او محليا من خلال السيطره
على الوضع الفوضوي في هونج كونج السيطره
على الوضع درس لتايوان حول ضروره الالتزام
بسياده القانون
اقليميا يبقى ملف اعاده ضم تايوان
والسيطره على الشارع في هونغ كونغ من ابرز
الملفات التي يتعامل معها الرئيس سوشي
فبعد اخماد احتجاجات عام 2019 في هونغ
كونغ عمل على تعزيز ولاء الحكومه المحليه
هناك لبيجين احتجاجات كانت تنادي بتعزيز
الحريات والديمقراطيه لكنها انتهت
باعتقالات ومحاكمات بموجب قانون جديد
للامن القومي شيماء تويي الجزيره فيجيم
وبينما ننهي حصاد الليله نتذكر محنه قرابه
مئه وتسعه وعشرين الف شخص وصلوا الى الحد
الاقصى من انعدام الامن الغذائي ويواجهون
خطر الموت في منطقه القرن الافريقي الكبرى
التي تشهد جفافا رهيبا منذ عده سنوات
وبحسب مركز التوقعات والتطبيقات المناخيه
التابعه لايجاد وهو تجمع دول شرق افريقيا
فان الظروف الراهنه اسوا مما كانت عليه
قبل جفاف عام 2011 الذي ادى الى مجاعه
تسببت في وفاه الاف الاشخاص هذه المنطقه
من بين اكثر المناطق عرضه لتغير المناخ مع
ازمات متكرره وشديده بشكل متزايد ووقت
تذكر فيه قيمه التضامن باشكالها المختلفه
حتى يتجاوز سكان هذه المنطقه محنتهم دمتم
بخير والى اللقاء
[موسيقى]